(gentle rock music)
(marker scratches)
- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan here.
Biology is the study of living systems,
and you can look all around you
and even at yourself to
recognize that living systems
and biology
and nature is fundamentally creative.
And for us to understand it,
we have to be even more creative.
But don't take my word for it.
I'm gonna introduce you to some
of my close friends
who can even better draw
this link between biology
and creativity.
(keyboard keys clicking)
(marker scratching)
- Creativity is super important in biology
because it's hugely important
(keyboard keys clicking)
in the process of evolution.
Evolution often takes a winding path
to get to what we see now,
and if we wanna follow this path
in an attempt to understand it,
sometimes we've gotta be as resourceful
and clever as evolution has been.
That requires creativity
in how we solve problems,
and even creativity in
the questions we ask.
- Creativity is so important
for anybody who is thinking
(keyboard keys clicking)
about, who is studying biology.
Because the question we're
trying to understand is not
just, take in all the information
that we know about biology.
We want people to imagine what biology,
what the natural world,
what the physical world, you know,
what our bodies can actually do,
what our brains can do.
And to be able to do that,
you need to think out of
the box, you need to think
about things that haven't
been thought about before,
and that is why biology,
that is why creativity is so critical
for anybody studying biology.
- Creativity isn't
exclusive just to the arts,
but it also spans into science
(keyboard keys clicking)
and technology
and engineering
and mathematics.
Creativity
and science comes down to,
thinking about a problem or a situation,
and how best to approach that problem
or situation from multiple angles.
So, when you approach a
problem in the real world,
it won't be multiple choice,
like you may have in school.
It actually would be
something that requires you
to think about that particular situation,
and apply other things you've learned
about it to be creative,
and to come up with answers
that may not have been
familiar to you before.
(keyboard keys clicking)
(marker scratching)
- One question that people ask me is,
how do I apply creativity
to the presentations
(keyboard keys clicking)
that I give?
And my secret sauce is to come up
with a visual image that anybody,
I don't if you're the adult,
whether you're a fifth
grader or second grader,
that you can grasp that concept.
And here's my favorite one.
So every single time you move your body,
there's whole bunches of neurochemicals
that are released in your brain.
And you've heard of these
neurochemicals: dopamine,
noradrenaline, serotonin.
And so, that's the fact,
but the image that I give is
that every single time you move your body,
it's like giving your brain
a wonderful bubble bath
of neurochemicals that enrich your brain,
that change that neurochemical milieu,
and that is the image
that everybody that comes
to my talks leaves with,
and inspires them a little bit
(gentle electronic music)
to move their body more.
So can you come up with that image,
that playful, fun,
but factually accurate image
that conveys your message.
That will be your secret sauce too.
- Have you heard that the
bees aren't doing great?
Well, I've been studying that,
(keyboard keys clicking)
and trying to understand
how their complex health issues connect
to a curious little parasite
that's in nearly every
honeybee colony worldwide.
It's called Varroa Destructor, by the way.
Now, before I started this study,
we thought the that it was an open
and shut case, that the
parasite was sucking
out the bee's blood, sort
of like a tick on a puppy,
but I thought something more
strange might be going on.
The damage that it caused just didn't seem
like the damage that would
be caused by blood removal.
The feeding process is super
difficult to see though,
so, I had this idea.
I fed different color
glowing food to the bees
in their pollen
and their sugar water,
to color their organs specific colors.
Then, when the parasite fed on the bees,
I could tell which organ it was eating,
based on which color was
in its digestive system,
and it turns out that they
were eating the bee's liver,
by the way, which is pretty weird,
but, this kind of work
is actually pretty fun.
And it was definitely a place
where creativity was rewarded in biology.
(keyboard keys clicking)
(marker scratching)
Some of the world's greatest
discoveries have been reached
by applying creative thinking
(keyboard keys clicking)
to scientific questions.
Here's a good example.
I have been super
inspired by the creativity
of the Geiger-Marsden
gold foil experiments,
since I was in high school.
They have helped us understand
the structure of an atom,
and atoms make up pretty much everything
we can interact with,
biological or otherwise.
Like, you can't see an atom,
so, you've gotta get
creative to figure out
how its pieces are all laid out.
We used to think
that its positive charge was
pretty evenly spread out,
but this research team fired a beam
of positively charged
particles at gold atoms,
and found that a bunch
of them bounced off,
while even more of them
passed straight through.
And this suggested that
the positive charge
in the atom was concentrated
in a small part,
because some of the positive
particles were upheld,
like the two positive poles
of like, two separate magnets,
but much of the rest of the
atom must be empty space,
because a bunch of the
particles passed right through.
Because of this absolutely genius way
of visualizing what we can't see,
we now know the structure of the stuff
that makes up the observable universe.
(upbeat synthpop music)
And, because
of this pioneering research,
we've got everything from nuclear power
to MRI machines, even the
life saving technology
that's inside of the smoke
detectors in your home.
(keyboard keys clicking)
(marker scratching)
So, the first step discoveries
is always the same.
(keyboard keys clicking)
Figure out your question.
Maybe you wanna know where
fireflies go during the day,
or how mosquitoes find people to bite.
And then you should create a hypothesis.
Maybe mosquitoes find people
by following the smell of sweat
and their breath, then
consider what must be true
for your hypothesis to be true.
You might not be able to test a mosquito's
smell receptors directly, but
if your hypothesis is true,
people who are exercising,
and thus exhaling a lot,
and producing more sweat,
should attract more mosquitoes.
Actually, I probably
shouldn't encourage you
to experiment on humans.
Why don't you maybe try the
firefly question instead?
- Young people can get
creative in science,
(keyboard keys clicking)
by using not just science
but other things that they're learning
from their life,
and connecting it to science
or connecting science to other things
in their life such as art,
and other things that are outside
of the traditional STEM fields.
For example, when you're looking at,
or wondering about how something works,
like an mRNA vaccine, or
how the organ systems work,
you can use other aspects of your life,
and learn to make, or draw analogies
between different systems.
That's a really important
aspect of being creative
and using critical thinking,
because a lot of systems are similar
to other systems, even though
they use different names
or look very different,
and you can expand on your knowledge
on something by being creative,
or using other things outside of science
to draw connections
between different fields
and different things.